ich habe ihn nicht geschlagen okay ich
habe über meine fahrt weiter hallöchen
freunde herzlich willkommen zurück zur
capt minecraft part 15 in den letzten
part hat gommel sag mal was zuletzt
geschafft hast ich habe den gas getötet
mit seinen eigenen waffen und dadurch
auch das archiv wind bekommen und die
world dollar dadurch erweitert und heute
können wir nun mal noch dadurch eine
weitere so truhe denke ich mal was da
oben er da oben und ja da werden wir
glaube ich gleich mal hingehen oder
genau wir stehen in dieser folge nach
oben gehen weil er meint dass dadurch
jetzt dass die world bauder
weitergegangen ist dass sich dadurch
irgendwie in truhe offenbart hat und
dann wenn ihr wollt wir dann noch mal
weiter geht sehen wir hier schon ist
hier noch mal in ruhe an der name da
wieder coole sachen dran und alles mit
10 toren in der nächsten folge was ihren
einer der letzten folge was ihr nicht
gesehen habe komme sondern was ich hier
so gemacht hat ist ich habe richtig viel
messen gekümmert da schon jedoch richtig
viel da ist auch noch was drin und das
sind alles hühnchen das seht ihr schon
richtig das ist nämlich ganz einfach der
fall weil hier sind einfach so viele
hühnchen wir haben einfach letztens
schon mal so eine farm gemacht hier hat
er mitbekommen und mich als ein mal
reingehen weil er jetzt gerade
vielleicht hat nicht weil es gerade
trotz wir da gemacht habe aber ich hab's
locken schon wieder 4 13 münchen wieder
und alles markante so viel essen und das
ist richtig geil und wer im recht viel
zu essen nur eine kuh fehlt wenn ihr
eventuell wisst wurde diese kuh abhanden
gekommen ist dann schreibt des ordens
das kann doch irgendwie sagen dass
unsere koubek es werden ja drei kühe wir
haben ja sogar schon mal gepaart gehabt
ja ja ja ja komisch na ja gut ich würde
sagen ich kann jetzt mal zu dir hoch ich
nehme ein bisschen fit und in der höhle
ist unten ja ich kämpfe gegen 1000
monster auch gut somit nicht mehr nach
oben gehen ich habe hier übrigens auch
ein pilz farm gemacht ob die
funktioniert also wenn du mir noch
leiter noch einmal runterbringen würdest
wer ist ob es so kommen sonst kann ich
mir leid ich mach dir selbstverständlich
noch ein paar ich meine art alles
gesprengt und da ist jetzt nicht mehr
viel von übrig von den ganzen leitern
soll dann nämlich hier noch ein bisschen
aber ich habe nen bogen für dich dann
hätte es komplett kaputt aber ich hatte
immerhin supercool
dann haben wir hier voll die mob fall
also ohne witz hier sind so viele
monster geräusche wieder das genauso wie
wenn du irgendwann zu weihnachten sagt
wir kommen hier ist für dich eine
schokolade gekauft in schock war zu
weihnachten genau ich habe einfach
ansporn raum gefunden also ins bonner ok
dann lasst uns eine coole war ein baum
genau so wenn du jemand zuhause einsatz
kommen ich hab den schokohasen für dich
aber ich hab dir schon halb aufgegessen
ich sehe ich sag ich mal zu dir kommen
bricht aber die frame sein
[Musik]
hier sind einige skelette ich habe ihn
nicht geschlagen und ich glaube ich habe
doch habe ich die scheibe die
schallplatte eingesammelt juli das
fordert schon mal zerstört ich hab dir
leider mitgebracht übrigens hier kannst
du hier eben schon reparieren hier
da bei dem beim leiter turm
kannst du dann vielleicht war dieses
springen doch was die verursacht hast da
irgendwie zu bauen aber es ist da für
mich auch hier untergegangen weil man
durch die halt die knochen erhält und
das sporne abgebaut
den hat der körper gesprengt aber wofür
braucht man den ja für xp vielleicht
oder so was kommen
ich hab damit diese scheiß world dollar
legte ich will die seite das damalige
wehrführer und ein bild so stemmer
fordert wird jetzt einfach so 10
diamanten liegen oder so ich würde so
schnell hier alle erfolge machen
plötzlich schaffen wir alles in einer
folge und alter die kuh unsere kuranyi
das ist gar nicht die kursschwächen
könnten ja ich habe ihnen die zwei gold
nugget zum inventar ich habe keine
ahnung wo die herkommen gut soll das
geht natürlich jetzt in alle richtung
hier weil meine spielzeug kaputt
es geht natürlich jetzt in alle
richtungen weiter das heißt wir können
auch hier mal ganz kurz gucken was hier
eventuell noch ist und eventuell wieder
das ganze ein bisschen ausholen hier
habe ich gesagt wir gehen immer nach
oben oder genau ich bin auch schon
wieder rum
ich komme eben auch mit aber das ist
einfach mal eine schlafende fledermaus
äußerst knuffig heute zeit aufgebracht
so ich komme aber nach oben ich lager
dann ganz normal meine sachen aus
fressen wir noch kurz raus und dann je
nach oben die kiste luton aber da sind
jetzt nicht mehr flimmert seit ich muss
jetzt nicht großartig auf den kampf
vorbereiten oder als nämlich eigentlich
gar nicht okay super ist pflanzt ja noch
so packen für sachen kann ich die
münchen gleich sparen
ich hoffe brauchen alles andere muss
aber einfach noch ein laufen oder liegen
einfach zehn millionen eier schon die
ganze eier ja wann immer du dich mal da
ich hab auch ne ich habe doch keine mehr
achtung jetzt geht's ab hier jetzt
geht's ab conny kuck mal wer hier wird
usa deutlich gebremst wird da alter
fahrer mit
das problem ist behoben weil wir darum
braucht einfach kurz darauf dann läuft
wieder
das kann man mit goldlack machen kann
man sich daraus nicht gold blöcke machen
da kann man damit brown kann man auch
glaube ich ja noch ein bisschen weiter
an
ja ist ja auch gerade gewachsen so
brauchst du noch erläutern
gerade gar keine ich kann dir immer
gerne neben da aber eigentlich brauchen
wir doch gar keinen okay wir haben auch
noch 13 13 beizen das reicht auch noch
für richtig viele also bescheid gern
auch bescheid sondern packt ihr nochmal
da rein dann natürlich noch im kohlenhof
und danach schicken wir mal nach oben
du machst ist aber auch spannend hier
mit der true da oben du die die
zuschauer müssen dran bleiben wir sehen
wollen was die natur richtig was zu
essen wie heute dann will ich sagen ich
mach mal los zu truhe die ranke wächst
war gar nicht am ende habe ich mich voll
getäuscht und er kann sein dass
irgendwie naturschnee streiks wie wir in
epik maps in der nähe oder die ist immer
noch nicht freigelegt ich hoffe schon
also die müsste eigentlich frei sein
dann müssten jetzt auch wieder diamanten
frei sein also kannst du gleich
diamanten mit abbauen und die kann man
da oben ist lapislazuli und kohle alter
du bist schon ziemlich hoch gegangen
sehr hoch wir können auch der opa auf
diesen esser insel
theoretisch hier sind wieder zwei
münchen hier warte warte du bist schon
dran vorbei jedoch nicht wir müssen
jetzt wieder so viele hühner die braucht
doch kein mensch
doch wir euch jetzt wieder alles alter
wir müssen eigentlich alle ganzen boten
so irgendwie aus wasser machen dass wenn
man runterfällt dass das dann dass da
nichts passiert irgendwie stimmt und
nenne da kommen wir jetzt noch nicht ran
oder aber kommen wir doch an
nee bekomme alle zuschauer denken sich
sogar cool danach richten welche erfolg
können wir auch machen jetzt ganz
schnell einmal gucken ich guck mal ich
guck mal eben ganz kurz rechne ich
machen muss das ende finde das ende
okay das dauert noch ne verzaubert
verwende einbuchen die dafür bot
zuckerrohr wein trank bücherregal machen
dafür brauchen wir bambus diamanten
schwert könnte man nie dafür müssen wir
mal den verzauberung haben fliege auf
einem schwein eine klippe hinunter dafür
müssen die schweine pannen können wir
könnten kuchen machen
dafür wollen wir zu recht jetzt ja
zucker aus
und jetzt fangen wir kriegen ersten drei
erfolgen oder so töte ein skelett mit
einem pfeil aus einer entfernung von
mehr als 50 metern
das können wir machen von hier oben das
sehen wir jetzt geld holt
du hast ja wohl einen bogen erst mal für
dich bogen besorgt das ist ein punkt
dieser ihn an
und noch ein paar pfeile ja leider
liegen obwohl ganze mit runterkommen und
probieren aber wie kriegen wir dann
hatten haben sie schaffen wir das weil
das geht doch eigentlich nur bei nacht
wir müssten alles ableuchten also die
stimmen damit haben wir auf den 8 watt
und die nacht dauert die sonne geht
unter
wir haben glück er kommt nach unten
kommen gleich jeder zwei münchen an
hier sind schon wieder münchen frei
alter ist das krass bei den ganzen also
ich brauch mal die ganzen oh wir dürfen
nicht unsere code töten mit dem pfeil
steverforums die kuh und auch die ranken
sie wachsen hätte ich okay cool
wofür brauchen wir dann ranken überhaupt
doch die braucht man gar nicht aber eine
ahnung von exit here in the spring als
wasserauffangbecken ich finde es traurig
dass wir die hühner nicht paradis
müller nicht bank können genau dass wir
die schweizer nicht parken weil sonst
können wir schon auf dem schweine klippe
herunter fliegen ja oder die kühe nicht
weil wenn wir die kühe wenn wir leider
bekommen wir haben drei leder reicht das
für ein sattel
das meine ich gar nicht koscher ist aber
deutet nur ich muss mit töten
wir haben schon eine kugel tötet er in
der tat dass ich jetzt noch nicht
freigeschaltet
deswegen ach du hast ich habe schon
freigeschaltet ist okay wenn schweine
fliegen flieger auf einem schwein an die
kripo unter her wie macht man denn einen
sattel kann ich mal eben nach gucken ja
wie gut ich habe das sehr einfach wir
brauchen nur fäden als das können wir
gebrauchen drei leder und leser haben
wir ja gar nicht doch wie ich wir haben
drei leder
ja ich habe drei leder ja dann brauchen
wir zwei fehlen und 212 fäden habe ich
auch so läuft wie sogar daher nicht
früher
doch sie drücken wir heute noch in der
nachfolge luton so und doch kein eisen
nicht doch im ofen noch mit hallo jetzt
kommen
jetzt war ich mich nicht wir haben kein
eisen wir auch kein eisen
[Musik]
ach ne ne ne ne ne helder ich gehe ich
dir unter aber zwei lang soll wir waren
nur zwei eisen da muss irgendwo eisen
quelle sein wieso habe ich dann keine
zwei krisen mehr
doch selbst kagawas abgebaut wir hätten
keine rüstung kaufen dürfen ja kaufen
[Musik]
da gibt man geld aus gleich wird es auch
dunkel haben alle beweise haben
ok jetzt erstmal walzen noch damit aber
eben die hühnchen dich nicht du stinkst
war die hier so also ich bin auf dem weg
nach oben
das ist so witzig wenn man aber als das
knackige durchläuft einfach wieder 16
112 eier habe ich gerade wieder ganz
hühnereier wirft also wenn ich mich
einfach nichts daran dass kohle kohle
kohle wollen wir kohle in der selten
kiste
die ab geht's wir können ja eigentlich
zwei erfolge machen ein skelett
abschießen von da oben und mit den
schweinen darunter fliegen oder wir
haben zwei minuten da ist noch alles
schaffen ich versuche erst mal dass wir
jetzt das eisen wie genau muss sich die
anordnen
unten links und unten rechts ein stück
eisen wasser ok und ja mitte links mitte
rechts ein stück immer ein faden ja und
oben dreimal leder also so in einfach
einmal quer lang über eine gleichheit
geht nicht was ich geb dir mal die
sachen versuchte mal hier
ich habe jetzt gerade hingeschmissen
com hat den erfolg schubser erzielt und
so sie denn gemacht gestand hinterher du
stehst du nur um den erfolg erzielt geht
das nicht hier auf dem bild das auch shi
bestimmen kommentar also so macht man
das aber sind nur drei auf der map sich
ein anderes rezept dafür brauche ich
drei eisen gibt und dafür brauchen
brauchen wir fünf leder aber es geht
doch nicht den vater habe ich noch nie
gesehen
ich glaube ich glaube man kann sich auch
keine kraft man findet ihn nur irgendwie
ja ja glaube ich nämlich auch da
minecraft wiki dasteht
[Musik]
sattel können nicht hergestellt werden
aber man kann sehen tun von verließen
verlassenen mieden festung und
wetterfesten finden einer höhle finden
wir wahrscheinlich
[Musik]
der erfolg nur mist machen vielleicht
werd hochgehen das pony unten monster ok
warte ich nehme einen bogen mit meinem
bergen werben und dabei also wir können
eigentlich direkt nach oben so die
fackeln sind weg genau aber hier noch
nicht einfach da vorne beim fällt ja ich
habe dann geht das feld kaputt als ob
das braucht doch nicht gehen können wir
da das irgendwie
[Musik]
vielleicht sponti jeder ecke noch ja hmm
was haben wir davon auf keinen fall die
gutachter kommen so so so viel ist klar
ja wohl sachlich sagte er und verschwand
nicht dass da oben erzählen wir schon
mops exporten sondern schließlich
darunter mit tot
wir sollten vielleicht einmal die
leitung so ein bisschen auswirkten
ja obwohl gerade ausleuchten wir glaube
ich nicht ganz so gut so ja ich will
nicht zu hoch gehen wir hätten
vielleicht macht die entfernung gucken
sollen
doch so hoch sind das sind locker das
sind locker noch keine 50 blöcke oder
noch nicht ganz aber naja was du nicht
willst du nicht getötet kann das skelett
hayta waren es gelernt hochzeiten können
nee da guckt man die leiter die geht
doch noch weiter oben machen
dort können die auch die fackel jetzt
werke wie die noch weiter höhe
ach packe ich diese ganzen hühner hier
ne ich würd sagen wir mal in der
nächsten folge mit dem erfolg mit einem
skelett das ist also ich glaube das wird
noch so viel arbeit wir können da von
hier oben nicht mal sehen ob darunter
skelette sind ja aber wir können ja ich
habe schon die idee ihr könnt ihr das so
machen das wäre ihr müsst ihr einfach
genau dass wir eben gerade machen du
hast mir nichts plötzlich runterschubsen
denn hier oben 1 ist ja das hast du
wieder alles falsch gemacht habe ja ja
ja egal gut freude wir haben
jetzt uns vorgenommen dass wir diese
beiden nächsten erfolg mit dem schuh mit
dem nicht mit dem kopf sondern mit dem
schwein mit dem skelett dann in der
nächsten morgen
und wenn ihr das sehen wollt dann lasst
bewertung da und schott morgen
willkommen die folge und wir sehen uns
dann morgen wieder schübe du